president Trump's impeachment started
today yeah it was the first day they
spent the day did you watch this they
spent the day debating the rules yeah
yeah that's true yeah Democrats want to
use the exact same rules this is true
Democrats want to use the exact same
rules you're used during the Clinton
impeachment trial same ones yeah in
other words they want it simulcast on
pornhub
[Applause]
it's the way I'd see it frankly the
rules this is the rules are coming up
the rules state that during the trials
senators are not allowed to drink
anything but water and milk that's true
yo or as Mitt Romney calls that a full
bar yeah it's come out that only two
cameras are allowed in the Senate Jim
chamber only two yeah and get this one
of them is a kiss cam so Grassley and
Graham the kiss do it do it this is
where it according to a new poll that
just came out 61% of American women
disapprove of President Trump 61% yeah
and the 30 the 39% who do approve of
Trump had terrible fathers
[Applause]